Speaker 1: Let's go next.
As we take phone calls, let's go to let's
go back to Rhode Island.
Let's go to Jen from Providence, Rhode Island.
Speaker 5: Hey, David, can you hear me?
Yes, I can, John.
All right.
Is this speaker weird?
All right, so I have a question.
I know that you're interested in social and
history and everything.
Sure.
Have you looked into what happened after the
1918 pandemic, how there was a similar kind
of labor shortage and how workers used it
to demand higher wages?
And there was kind of a social movement going
on and then the Teamsters rose up?
Speaker 1: That's very interesting.
Speaker 5: Yeah.
Do you think we're kind of repeating history
with that and we might be able to use this
to our advantage to get better wages?
Speaker 1: Yes.
In fact, I did a story on the Wednesday show
about the spread of strikes and worker protests
across the country and made the point that
the pandemic may have generated.
The ideal maybe is a little too much, but
favorable conditions for workers to use newfound
leverage to demand better working conditions
and better wages.
Now, as far as 1918 and the flu, I did not
know I've studied the 1918 pandemic a bit
and we've done one or two interviews about
it.
I didn't know about the impact there on strikes
and worker rights beyond just it was the tail
end of the progressive era during which we
saw activism for wages and better working
conditions, but as as ushered in by the pandemic,
I wasn't familiar with that, and I will look
into it.
That sounds interesting.
Speaker 5: Yeah, and it was kind of the same
thing now what's going on now?
There was a huge wage gap.
And those workers that for the first time
were able to afford things like automobiles
and appliances, they were coming into existence.
The middle class rose to be until the, you
know, in 1929 when the stock market crashed.
So I kind of wonder, you know, where at the
same wage gap that maybe we could kind of
make up some of the space?
Yeah.
What they did hundred years
Speaker 1: ago, that I mean, it's it's possible
and we're going to keep following these strike
movements and see see what they develop.
And, you know, I would from a from a self-centered
standpoint, I would love that.
And a lot of times people say, David, I don't
understand like, why are you saying it would
be good for you for workers to earn higher
wages?
Like how does that affect you?
And as I've explained so many times before,
the way I earn money is by people getting
memberships on my website and buying the products
and services sold by my advertisers.
That's how that's how I make money.
If an advertiser does well, they buy more
ads.
And so if more people have disposable income,
they're not living paycheck to paycheck.
That's dramatically growing the pool of people
that can afford to get a membership or buy
something from an advertiser.
So I am thrilled about these protests because
I think that they're the right thing and that
workers deserve rights.
And also from a selfish standpoint, as an
entrepreneur, it's great for me as well.
And so I don't get the wholehearted opposition
that we see from so many places.
Speaker 5: Yeah, I'm in a similar boat as
that, I'm a waitress and people are going
to tip more if they had a little bit of extra
money in their pocket.
Speaker 1: Absolutely.
It's demand side stimulus and whether you
know that that's what it is or you don't.
Working people understand that when people
have more money, it's also better for me.
Speaker 5: Yeah, and just better for the economy
overall and better for, you know, depression,
things like that, people are just happier.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
All right.
Well, I thank you.
You are my favorite YouTuber.
And hey, it's my birthday tomorrow.
So this is a good early birthday party.
Speaker 1: All right.
Happy early birthday, Jen from Providence.
Great to hear from you.
Really, really strong phone calls today.
It's actually shocking me.